this is a production of cornell
university
great um so yeah i'm going to be talking
about this buzz word of resilience
and within the context of the work and
my group
works really largely most of our work is
actually at the field and farm scale a
lot of on-farm research
but actually today i'm going to talk
more about some of the
work at the rhizosphere and then broader
regional systems scale
work that we're doing i'm going to start
so i don't run out of time later
acknowledging the many collaborators
who've contributed to some of the work
i'm going to share today
current and former graduate students as
well as
collaborators here at colorado state
university
and also we have great partners here
with usda ars
just down the road and funding sources
so
here's what i'm hoping to do today um
in a story in three parts uh
part one is going to be super short even
though that's where the bulk of my work
probably is but i decided that this
group might not be super excited about
dry land wheat systems so i'm not going
to focus as much on that work today
so i'm going to focus a little more on
this part 2 increasing internal nitrogen
regulation
and looking at resilience from this very
field
scale and even plant soil microbe scale
interactions and then
at the end i'm going to jump into a very
different scale
and touch on somewhat cursory
this idea of resilience at a much
broader scale where we bring the human
systems and the social systems into play
and talk about some of the work we're
doing in that space
so first i'm going to start with
there was a nice paper a few years ago
by katie peterson and emily gowden and
that group
talking about resilience in ag systems
and i do think it's important because
this word gets used a lot to think about
what we mean when we say resilience
and it's really you know from a from an
ecological perspective it's largely been
this idea of can a system maintain
its current functioning in the face of
disturbance and
our agricultural systems have largely
sort of maintained
their current productivity levels
largely uh
through some external inputs whether
that's fertilizers and or in our region
irrigation water
and other inputs i would also argue
there's other external inputs
like policies programs
markets things like that that also
deepen that cup
to stabilize our current systems
and then there's quite a few of us who
work in this space
of how do we deepen that cup through
biology through ecology thinking about
enhancing reservoirs and internal
regulation of some of these processes
both carbon and nitrogen
water conservation pest and disease
management for example and how do we
build the internal capacity of these
systems to manage
and maintain their productivity in the
face of disturbances
so i'm going to start from this from
this perspective in this definition of
resilience i will broaden it later but
we're going to start here
for today and i wouldn't be a former
student of lori drinkwater if i didn't
show you a diagram of the nitrogen cycle
and this is actually
from a chapter that we wrote together
several years ago
on ecological nutrient management and
it's a nice way to just emphasize that
most of the bulk of the work looking at
nitrogen management and ag systems over
the past
50 60 decades has focused on that blue
box of inorganic end management
management of our fertilizers their
inputs their crop uptake
and their retention recycling in the
system
however despite those decades we know
that nutrient use efficiency
specifically fertilizer nutrient use
efficiency still remains at about 50
percent
and this is supported by several
different studies um
you know older and newer that 50
of our cereal crop nitrogen even in our
heavily fertilized systems
does not come from that year's nitrogen
fertilizer and it comes from
residues litter but largely from soil
organic matter
and so that's where um we are focusing
more there's been a lot of work we know
we credit
organic matter and say nutrient
recommendations if you send soil to a
testing lab things like that
but we haven't really intentionally
managed that as a nitrogen source
in our systems so one way
that we can build these reservoirs of
soil organic matter and therefore
nitrogen supply and capacity of our
systems
is intensification of our cropping
systems and by intensification i do not
mean
intensification of inputs but
intensification of vegetation
so how do we fill those gaps in the
cropping system
by growing crops that might build say
soil carbon retain nitrogen
and thereby building those nutrient
reservoirs in the system
so i had a student who've completed a
recent meta-analysis for example
just confirming what i think we already
knew to some extent that
having cover crops in the systems
consistently
fills one of those fallow periods and
builds soil carbon
that is that building of soil carbon is
dependent on
not too surprisingly how much biomass is
produced the soil texture to stabilize
that carbon
as well as the growing window and the
climate interactions between those
factors
between the biomass and the texture that
stabilized that soil carbon
and the dry land systems out here so i
work mostly in our wheat based
winter wheat based systems here where
the main historical rotation
has been one year of winter wheat
planted september
harvested the following july and then a
14-month
fallow period maintained without weeds
used to be more tillage now it's more
herbicide managed
to store soil water for the following
crop and so we've been doing quite a bit
of work at looking at
systems that have successfully reduced
the frequency of that fallow period
because it's
very damaging for both the soil quality
but also the emergence of herbicide
tolerant weeds
and net profitability and so we have
strong evidence that taking
reducing that fallow so intensifying the
vegetated periods in our systems can
increase soil carbon
and that does feed back to more nitrogen
availability
as well as net profitability due to
reduced in
inputs relative to the crops produced
and then building from that we also have
some more recent work looking at
it's not just biomass but actually the
quality of that biomass does matter
so as we intensify these systems going
from winter wheat to say maybe a winter
wheat with a
corn or a millet other crops that
actually integrating a legume into those
rotations
enhances the stabilization of
that carbon those residue inputs into
more mineral associated organic matter
pools
so it's not just intensification but it
also depends on the diversity of the
crop types and integrating
legumes in that system helps build those
nutrient
reserves faster so
i could spend a whole seminar on those
topics of just rotation systems
um and mechanisms of building organic
matter but instead i'm going to shift
and focus more on a couple of somewhat
simple
more preliminary greenhouse studies
where we're starting to ask the question
of
okay so we can build more organic matter
pools and actually we can do it those
examples i just shared
did not come with increased fertilizer
inputs to build that carbon right that's
one of the concerns that's
been coming up with building soil carbon
as well you need nitrogen to do it but
those intensification examples i just
shared
are not actually they're just using the
available
new nitrogen that was already
inefficiently being used in that system
so now the question is okay so we have
some organic matter how do we manage
that system and can we design crops that
better access and utilize
soil organic matter nitrogen as opposed
to
fertilizer nitrogen uptake so
that's this is one study done by uh
master student my candice carter
where we worked with 10 different canola
genotypes
from the nested association mapping
lines so we knew
sort of the genetic makeup of some of
these unfortunately there wasn't a lot
of
root traits and below ground traits that
we could choose from so we had just
diversity in general with similar
phenology it was how we selected these
10 different genotypes
with a hypothesis that there would be
genetic variation
in the ability of these different canola
types to access different forms of
nitrogen
and so we grew these under four
different
treatments in a greenhouse study one was
a high soil organic matter
and one was a low soil organic matter
crossed with a high fertilizer
and low fertilizer the high organic
matter was about a six percent or
uh sorry four percent organic matter
compared to a one percent
um and then we crossed that with um
these different fertilizer rates
and the the punch line was genotype
didn't matter and i think this is
actually
an example of soil ecologists
biogeochemists trying to dive into
genetics and breeding territory when
they don't
always know what they're doing meaning
that we would have needed to have
much higher replication and i see this
again and again with these studies the
genotypic variation
factors are quite subtle and we try to
see them with more of an ecology lens we
don't always design our experiments in a
way that do that so
we've been learning from that but so
genotype didn't matter
so this is all of the 10 canola lines
lumped together across those four
different soil treatments
again high soil organic organic matter
high fertilizer
across the bottom here all the way to
low low
and what we see that i think is
important to
to consider is that
as we shifted from high organic
matter to low organic matter and added
high and low fertilizer
those nitrogen sources were more
additive than replacement
so what do i mean by this i mean that
they took up about the same amount of
nitrogen from
the organic matter regardless of the
fertilizer treatment with the one
exception of the very stressed
low low treatment the nitrogen stress
treatment where the plant was so stunted
it actually took up less nitrogen even
from the organic matter but in general
these were additive forms of nitrogen
oops ah wrong way um
such that if we look at the fertilizer
uptake rate this is often how we define
nitrogen use efficiency as the
percentage of the fertilizer added that
was taken up into the canola
we see that it's the same um at the high
organic matter levels
actually to the you know tenth of a
percentage here
um the only place where we see slightly
enhanced fertilizer uptake efficiency
was in the low organic matter high
fertilizer treatment
so canola was effective at utilizing the
soil organic matter nitrogen
this effect was additive but it wasn't
really a substitute
for fertilizer and then we've just been
starting to look at some of the more
microbial processes that
influence this nitrogen release and
trying to link that again to genotypes
and plant traits
again in this study genotype didn't
matter but there's a couple interesting
things that we did find
um so this is looking at extracellular
enzyme activity
in the soil and we looked at four
different enzymes um
and the results here follow the same
pattern from left to right
in terms of treatments high organic
matter treatments are on the left
low organic matter treatments are on the
the right of each of these
crossed with the fertilizer and what we
see is having more organic matter
in the system not too surprisingly
enhanced enzyme activity
across the board regardless of the
enzyme we are looking at
interestingly though in both organic
matter levels but particularly the low
organic matter level
adding that nitrogen fertilizer
suppressed enzyme activity regardless of
the enzyme
type so this is looking at the the
purple which is the low fert
versus the blue bar here which is the
high fruit with the low organic matter
backgrounds
and so we see that soil organic matter
enhanced enzyme activity and nitrogen
fertilizer suppress soil enzyme activity
even for our phosphorus cycling enzymes
so that's something that we're
continuing
to look at and puzzle out we did look at
ph as one consideration that did not
seem to be the reason
for this for this difference here
so that was one study just to look at
how how different plants we didn't find
a lot of plant mediation
in terms of genotype traits across the
system so
now i'm going to turn towards another
experiment where we use stable isotopes
to try to track some of these flows
and again this one not looking at
genotypes so much is looking at the
quality of the organic matter
in this case it was cover crop litter as
influenced by plant growth
and so in this study we grew corn which
is a c4
plant in a c3 soil background
in the greenhouse we also did a field
experiment similar to this one i'm going
to talk about the greenhouse one here
and into those pots we added different
litter bags
of cover crop that was m15 labeled
and the litter bags were separated in
each pot
one bag had root material one bag had
shoot material
and we had clover in one pot rye
and another pot of treatments and then
there were mixed treatments
across that and so that way what we
could do is track these different arrows
in here which is the 15n coming from the
cover crop
into say microbial biomass and into the
plant
we also tracked respiration of the plant
trying to separate background soil
organic matter or c3 derived soil
respiration versus plant drive c4
respiration
and then we also had nitrogen coming
from the organic matter
into the plant and otherwise there was
no no fertilizer added to these
they were in a background of soil sand
mixture
so we had pots um so four replicates
uh the treatments then were pots with
corn
and without corn most of the litter was
in these two millimeter mesh
size so the roots could access into
those litter bags
but we also within the corn did sets of
replicates where we did
um smaller mesh size this 35 micron mesh
which would exclude the roots but it
would allow mycorrhizae or hyphae to go
in
to see what the direct foraging effect
is of the roots versus
not what's the plant effect is it direct
or is it more indirect
through microbial mediation
and we used this is the setup in the
greenhouse we used a picaro
cavity ring down spectrometer to measure
the co2 from these pots
at only a couple time points and
and this gives you the details of the
litter one of the challenges of growing
n15 litter in the greenhouse is we had
to fertilize it so
it's important to note here that the c
to n
of say our clover which we would think
to be more nitrogen rich
was actually in terms of the shoots very
similar to our rye
carbon and nitrogen ratio and so where
we see differentiation is really in the
rye roots
which has a much higher sea to end ratio
than the clover
added to these different pots then we
did have a gradient
going from clover having the highest
nitrogen added as litter
and rye having the lowest
and so here are just some of the general
results in terms of the
crop the corn biomass across the study
across those four different litter bag
treatments
what we see is the corn grew just fine
with the litter
um having those litter bags in there
even with the rye
being you know as you said the shoe
material had a decent amount of nitrogen
in it
that did enhance overall plant growth
just having those litter bags in the in
the pots
we saw higher shoot biomass particularly
for our rye and clover
and we saw less root biomass
in our pots without without the litter
bags
what about then the corn effects on the
decomposition of that litter
we did see a significant effect across
the board in terms of corn increasing
the rate of decomposition of the litter
it did matter on the cover crop type as
well as
whether it shoot or root material so
that's what this shows here
is the percent of nitrogen lost from the
litter bag so sort of a mass
loss basically of the litter bag
we saw that corn enhanced the
decomposition of clover roots
and mixed clover rye roots but not
those lower quality rye roots themselves
and same with the shoot where we saw a
greater
corn effect in enhancing the
decomposition rate of the clover litter
interestingly remember the rye litter
had similar
course quality if we just measure that
with carbon and nitrogen ratio to the
clover
but obviously there's probably some
other biochemical differences in terms
of the quality of that of that rye liter
and it did not it was not
impacted by the corn in terms of
decomposition so
the corn is stimulating and accessing
particularly our nitrogen-rich
residues in this system in terms of one
of the other questions was
then does that stimulate priming then of
other background soil organic matter we
did not see
any effect of on the background
soil organic matter respiration rate
which is the blue bar
even though there's some differences
they're not significantly different
where we had corn versus not so corn
increased soil respiration that's the
red
here is the corn derived respiration so
not too surprisingly if you grow plants
in there the
roots are respiring and we see that
additive effect of respiration there
where we had our corn but we don't see
a cover crop effect or
a net effect on background
soil organic matter respiration in this
study
so then what about this question of the
different mesh sizes
in the direct the mechanisms by which
plants are
mediating this decomposition of litter
it did matter there was enhanced
decomposition
where we had the
extract access of the roots into the
litter so the two millimeter mesh size
across all three of our treatments here
had enhanced there was more nitrogen
that got
into the corn from that litter if
the plant roots had access to that
litter directly
versus indirectly in these 35 micron
mesh sizes so it is a direct
partnership between the roots accessing
that litter that increased the nitrogen
uptake into the plant
of that litter so these are just some
as i said kind of preliminary studies
but this is the direction that we are
we're starting some new work um so i
thought i'd bring it up and
be a good fodder for maybe some
discussion and questions later so some
future directions we're going with some
of this work
is to track again that below ground
track plant carbon below ground and try
to partition it more
into specific group traits root patterns
um
mycorrhizae as well as root exudates
and working with louise comas who's a
plant physiologist root physiologist to
look at some of those different root
traits
and how those then relate to
enhanced nitrogen acquisition of plants
from soil organic matter
as well as it's hard not to work on
water in our environment
here and so looking at some of these
root traits
that we know are good for drought
tolerance for example and to see
if that those have synergistic or
potentially trade-offs
for some of these traits that might be
advantageous for improving
the internal plant regulation of
nitrogen cycling from organic matter
pools
and so this is just an image from a
review of some of those drought traits
that we know
are advantageous in in terms of the
plant
for uptake and some of those than below
ground at least might be relevant to
nitrogen uptake as well
so that's parts one and two um
i am going to do a pretty major about
face
shift here and talking um to get to part
chapter three here
and this really comes from you know
doing work now
for quite a while in in farm systems and
practices at the field scale you know
thinking about these mechanisms at
smaller scales but at the end of the day
most of my work is
is at the farm scale and do a lot of
on-farm work with producers
and in through those conversations
and through interest that producers have
and some of these ideas about
intensification have been these
questions of okay
so some people are making these shifts
so i mentioned that the dominant
rotation system in our environment
is wheat and then fallow but in the last
five years or so for the first time we
did a landscape
analysis that it's now no longer the
dominant rotation
meaning rotation systems are shifting
and so then there's this question of how
and why
and what influences producer decisions
around whether to follow
fallow for example or to crop or to
buy into soil health movements or
not or regenerative ag or whatever the
the word of the day
is um and so it's really thinking about
how does that then fit into this broader
concept of resilience
and where do some farmers feel very
stuck in their current systems and where
are some
and why are some actually able to change
where others feel like there really are
no options
in terms of changing their systems
and so this is where i think it's really
useful to use this
much broader definition of resilience so
i've been focusing i would say i'm going
to call it in the absorptive capacity
the ability to maintain to persist
to maintain stability of production
systems
in the face of say you know disruptions
or the ability to rely less on external
inputs and have more internal cycling
capacity
but when we think about farming systems
in this broader context it really brings
into this question of adaptive capacity
and even shifting towards transformative
capacity
and the thing is what that requires is
flexibility
in our systems and so that's where i'm
going to shift now and thinking about
some of the work we've been doing at
broader scales
and so if we think about adaptive
capacity it's more than just the
physical assets on the farm
again it's that ability to make changes
and that requires an understanding of
the different organizational or networks
across our food systems amongst our
producers producers with other
institutions
where knowledge comes from and then i
think the one that
particularly in u.s ag systems we talk
about the least which is very important
is
the agency who is making decisions who
are the actors in the system
who do we serve as as researchers and
extension agents
um is it now less than two percent of
our population that
is doing the farming who are the actors
in these systems moving forward
and so this all comes together and
thinking about the
you know the adaptive capacity the
ability of the system to actually change
and this has become particularly
relevant um as laurie mentioned
we have a large project that it's
actually
technically ending as of right now but
we worked on for the last
six years focused on the the large
ogallala aquifer region
which touches parts of eight different
states in the central us
this dynamic figure here shows the
saturated thickness of that aquifer
through time
and it's incredibly heterogeneous that
big deep blue pool is under the sand
hills of nebraska it's not
agriculturally
farmed area for the most part but we see
that we have
deep dollar pockets throughout the
aquifer and
it's been really challenging in this
region where
you know for example as a researcher i
look at a nifa call and it says our goal
is to increase production by x percent
over the next
and we have regions here which no matter
what they do
they don't have much such much recharge
back to the aquifer especially on that
southern and western edges
increasing production is not
a wise goal for these regions what these
regions really need to think about is
how do they maintain the livelihoods
and what does agriculture look like or
what do their landscapes look like
moving forward the figure here
on the right is the scale at which these
decisions made so this is where
governance happens
if these groundwater management district
and smaller scales
linked to state water laws linked to
federal programs and policies
and so a lot of the conversation here
has been what is the value of that water
today versus tomorrow
and we through that work have identified
very strong social will that our
economic models don't capture
for example that values water tomorrow
rather than maximizing profitability
today
and then it's this question of we don't
have tools that
really help these farmers in envision
transitioning
to or these communities transition to a
new
economy or a new view of what those
landscapes might look like in the future
so that's kind of the water picture and
why building social capacity in these
systems is incredibly important if we
are going to
adapt and move forward within
you know the wheat based systems we've
done quite a bit of work
looking at why again producers choose
different rotation systems
and it comes down to some things that
are you know i think we all know
different sources of trusted information
different farm programs for example
it's really hard to ensure wheat if you
don't follow it due to that
that carryover legacy of what's been the
dominant management system
it's also mental models of different
individual producers in terms of risk
and some of it's real like to what
extent are they carrying debt versus not
um and then this mindset of
going to the coffee shop and talking
about yield versus
net profitability and the intensified
systems will not maximize
wheat yields but they will be more
profitable from the data we have but
there might be more risk in dry years so
how do we balance all of those pieces
and then this concept we've also been
talking
to farmers about urban interests and
i'll get into this a little bit more
and say prioritizing purchasing organic
wheat versus non which
requires different amounts of tillage
intensity so that gets into a whole
conversation of what is good farming
and farmer definitions of what good
farming is might be very
different from urban consumer
definitions and so how do we balance
some of those
those conversations um so this is
examples of you know we talk about
obstacles towards taking that fallow out
one of the big things that comes up is
we have grain you know markets in our
region for wheat
corn sorghum maybe millet and that's
pretty much it so
what are they going to diversify and
intensify with and how do we
how do we then again make the system
more flexible and adaptable
um and so that you know
we've been looking at how do we
capitalize on the fact
that there's a lot of consumers now that
are very interested
in where their food comes from and how
it's produced
and that's resulted in a plethora of
often confusing food labels
in the grocery store however it could
also be an opportunity so how do we
leverage that opportunity
to support some of these shifts
and have greater capacity and
flexibility in our rural communities
you know is it through say patagonia
grow
making long-root ale out of perennial
uh wheat is it you know markets for
pulse legumes in our region which would
really help as i said
increase opportunities for intensifying
these systems
field peas we've seen a growth in that
because there was a piece built
splitting plant that went into one
region in nebraska so all of a sudden
they grow
field peas but other regions you know
can't because we can't flood the market
with everyone going to that
and then there's you know actors in the
system like gene hediger
who has her own cooperative marketing
of different organic grains in our
region and is the largest organic millet
producer probably in the country now
because of that but
also then pools grains from other
growers
and is a marketing whiz you know so
there are all these different ways that
we
can or could potentially leverage this
consumer interest
in how and where food is grown and one
specifically that we've been looking at
here
is this program called the good food
purchasing program developed out of los
angeles
that has been increasingly develo
adopted by city procurement programs
as a way to sort of prioritize based on
different
criteria whether it's animal welfare
environmental stewardship
labor practices of where their food is
coming from
and so we've been working on with the
city of denver
and that hazard as many cities do now
has a food council and they are looking
at developing
and adopting some of these different
purchasing programs but there's no
farmers at the table in these
conversations so we've been trying to
flip this food system conversation
where we often talk about it from farm
to fork but
there's really forces pushing from fork
back to farm
and so how do we look at these different
consumer
institutional purchasing decisions and
think about how those
cascade back to the farm and producer
responses which
at the scale of a wheat farm might be no
change because that signal is really
small
the scale of the peach producers it
could be large enough for potato growers
in our region it could be large enough
to really change
how and what is produced in those
landscapes
and so we've been doing this through an
agent-based modeling approach
again using these as actors in the
system this is an example using potatoes
where we have different decisions in
there on
what's getting purchased in this case
it's fresh versus processed potatoes
organic versus non-organic potatoes and
that cascades all the way into
denver purchasing that can respond to
those policy interventions all the way
to a healthy eating index and one of the
main things we've learned through doing
interdisciplinary research is the
healthy eating index is largely
you know completely agnostic to how
things are produced and so it's really
about
what you know changing entirely
different products
that's going to influence some of the
health outcomes
and so that's been you know whereas farm
systems we often look at it from
individual crops
um so this has been a really interesting
and important exercise
for me to be part of to think about how
all these food system pieces
fit together
and so that comes back to then you know
this idea of
how do we link and understand these
systems so that there's
voice of both urban and um
rural actors at the table
in building more adaptive capacity in
these systems
and then also thinking about
how do we then potentially transition to
other systems
and how do we have productive flexible
and multifunctional
agricultural and cropping systems
there's
you know and so there's a question of to
what extent we can leverage
sort of these whole supply chain
approaches to foster different
ways that we manage our agricultural
landscapes whether that's you know
having perennial prairie strips
in there who you know where's the
ecosystem
function who who pays for that ex and
where do we
influence decisions about where those
are adopted
or is it intercropping systems where you
know we can leverage precision
technologies to sort lentils from oats
now
post harvest but again it comes down to
the marketing
potential of these different systems to
some extent to support these transitions
so i'm successfully i was hoping to be
done by five after i'm doing better than
i even thought i've whacked out a lot of
the field-based stuff so
we have lots of time for questions and
discussion
um so i want to thank you for your time
thank all the people here that are in
these images who contributed to this
work we have a couple different web
pages that
showcase our work and with that i'm
going to
stop screen sharing and um
take any questions if i can get
the right window here we go
yeah well thank you thanks megan
um so i think i saw a question come in
through the chat do you see those or do
you want me to
read read them out loud maybe that's
easiest
i do see them i can read them out loud
for the recording
right yeah um so
first question is is increasing soil
organic matter also have identifiable
increased concentration of
micronutrients
yeah we have not looked at that
specifically um
i think it it depends
um obviously if it's compost and manures
that are increasing soil organic matter
we know that we increase micronutrients
with that
if it's just cropping residues and
retention in those systems
they're retaining yeah i'm just going to
say we haven't looked at that
specifically
but organic matter has more than carbon
and nitrogen in it so we'll leave it at
that
more questions a question from tom hi
tom
um i recently heard that switchgrass has
an n fixing symbiont is this true and
might
have a role in the fallow yeah well we
can't really grow perennial tall grasses
here those are more for
uh further east from here but yes
there's been a lot of interest
in these associative and fixers you know
i mean there's even interest now in corn
mucilages that
fix knight you know have end fixers in
them as well
and i think there's a lot that we
don't know i mean sugarcane is well
known and reported to have
associ event fixers in that environment
that can contribute substantially to the
nitrogen balances of those systems
some of these others like switch grass
and some of these other perennial
grasses
i think that the evidence has been yes
they're there
and i don't think that it's at this
point been shown to be
agronomically a very large amount but i
think it's an important
important question to look at yeah i
think that's a great question
hi leilane um in your first experiment
of high and low organic matter
fertilizer combinations
did we use 15n fertilizer in order to
get an estimate
yes sorry i breezed over that the
fertilizer additions in that study were
all n15 enriched and that's how we got
that fertilizer uptake efficiency
estimates uh in that study yeah
so i didn't give that yeah
it looks like thomas might have his hand
raised
i can't see that i sure do go for it tom
good to see you megan
so i was wondering about the
the greater nitrogen use efficiency you
see in
legume-based systems
compared to where you're adding uh
inorganic nitrogen
how much of that effect do you think is
due to the direct
acquisition of organic nitrogen by the
roots
the way you've described it
yeah we haven't looked at that directly
my it's been a while since i looked at
that literature so i'd be happy for you
to correct me
my understanding is it's there plants
take up some organic forms of nitrogen
i haven't seen it be the dominant but i
think it'll be really interesting
if we try to well the decomposition i
mean that
that you were showing in your second
experiment
okay rephrase your question again for me
so
you're you're seeing that the um that
the
organic nitrogen in the soil is being
broken down directly by the roots
uh that that that's really a big
phenomenon so how
when you're adding organic nitrogen
either through cover cropping or legume
rotation what have you used the
observation
from lori long ago is that you see
much higher nitrogen use efficiency
and so it seems like this is a
this is clearly a mechanism that could
explain that
and i'm curious how much of that
phenomenon is
is due to that that the roots are
actually breaking down that organic
nitrogen
yeah i think it's i think it's a very
substantial
and there's part of that i think
it's one that organic matter nitrogen
is more stable and less readily lost
from the system
but two i do think that this
plant mediation of the decomposition and
that coupling
is part of the efficiency gained in in
talking with
and doing some cropping systems modeling
um
i remember collaborator armin kamanian
saying yeah
because we did some with with rye cover
crops
and the model kept underestimating how
much
that rye could grow in that soil
without a fertilizer and
it's totally anecdotal but he's like
yeah we kind of usually have a fudge
factor in there
because but i wonder to some extent if
the fudge factor in some of our models
that seem to underestimate the ability
of plants to access
you know to grow in low nutrient
environments
is some of that plant mediation that our
models just don't capture yeah
interesting good thanks yeah
hey megan i have a question and
um it's a bigger picture
question and it's somewhat political
so i just want to prime you um
but um when you're thinking about the
role
of a science and you're getting into
more social
ecological ideas um
how do you imagine uh the professional
societies that were a part of
being a more active force for
diversification
human diversification um a crop
diversification
but also yeah like it definitely
i think demographically there
is um some limitations within our
professional societies
in that regard as well but for crop
diversification
yeah um i mean i think
so i've been thinking a lot about sort
of who not so much professional
societies but like who our extension our
land grant extension serves
and and you know i kind of
touched on it that this idea that is a
really now less than two percent of our
population that's actually engaged in
farming
that we sort of serve and i think it
needs to be broader than that
so i think but to your question
specifically about crop diversification
i think
well i think there's a lot of things
that aren't necessarily just the
professional societies but we do a lot
that's commodity specific
and a lot that's not systems focused
so that is an obstacle for example and
that's even all the way through
you know some of these decision support
tools we've been working with
um you know cool farm tool for example
that it does greenhouse gas accounting
of different crops for
large food companies it's all single
crop focused i'm like well it depends if
you rotate your potatoes with barley
versus something else you know that's
going to impact your
your potato footprint and so
i think that there's there's a lot and
and those commodity groups do have
influence in in the societies in some
ways so there's that
um i think broader integration across
crop and soils is the other part i'm in
a
soil and crop science department and we
still
we try to not have those someone who
walks across those lines
a lot of my work i get a little
frustrated sometimes that we still silo
those two
two parts so i could go on and
if you have something else specific you
want but i do feel like a there's the
scale of the production systems there's
who's doing the farming
there's are we looking at systems versus
individual crops
obviously if you're doing crop breeding
you are going to be focused in on
on crops but we need these integrators
we need people
who integrate those concepts across
whole systems
yeah yeah all right i could tell that
you probably had some thoughts on it and
i've been thinking about
like how do you engage the organization
of the societies
that would allow for more integration
like
what does this structure what would this
structure
look like to achieve that function yeah
yeah
and i i would say the soil science
society is particularly i mean it's
still like
so physics so chemistry i see jonathan's
on here
my my first introductory soil science
professors
as online so um but i do think that you
know
the more we learn is obviously yes we
need expertise in some of these domains
but we really need integrated
group work across these if we're going
to solve some
[Laughter]
um looks like there's one more question
here how long will it take to have
increase in efficiency by adding cover
crops or their residue and field
conditions
is it the same season or a couple years
and also how long will it be beneficial
um
if we're building reservoirs that's a
long-term
proposition and a long-term benefit if
you know if you're just looking at
growing integrating a legume cover crop
and looking at its mineralization and
that residue that's
you know going to have a bulk of it
available within the first year and then
tailing off for the next few years
um so
when we see i don't know if you want me
to
get more i'm gonna that's a very general
answer to your question so if you have
something more specific
but what i'm talking about in terms of
building this resilience of the system
is building reservoirs that operate over
multiple years rather than focusing on
single years
in terms of that nutrient cycling
well i'm gonna i'll ask the question
here i'm not
are we seeing any others come in um
yeah so megan i'm just curious about
your um
regional project um
because often with those projects you
build a network and
you get to a certain point within the
grant cycle
and i'm just curious about it sounds
like there's a lot of
productive research done with that
interdisciplinary group and i'm
wondering about
next steps or if there are things that
are on a smaller
you know local scale within that region
that you think are
promising i'd just like to hear a little
bit about that
yeah i mean that's the challenge right
we i think
felt built a pretty strong network
and then the grand ends and so
there's a couple things that are going
to persist beyond the life of our grant
so that's really exciting there's a new
irrigator training program that brings
in the whole system perspective that's
engaging a lot of producers that weren't
otherwise engaged in some of these
conversations
the state of oklahoma was even
considering through their legislative
process
establishing their first ever
groundwater management district and i'd
like to think that our project actually
had a role
in that so we fostered a lot of
conversations about the value of water
that i think will persist beyond in
terms of the research you know
we spent five years building a really
cool integrated model
and so we are hoping we're actually
there's different entities actually the
state oklahoma
nrcs has a new initiative now trying to
look at the region as a
as a resource or conservation area um
and so there's different avenues that i
think that that will persist forward but
that is one of the big challenges of
these large
grant funded projects is then how does
it
how does it move forward once you've put
all the effort to build all those
relationships
great
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu